JASON SILVA: There
was a great scene
in a movie about
these two brothers
that wished to become writers.
We start learning about the
story of their unfolding lives,
the drama of their every day.
One of the guys falls
in love, and then
his girlfriend commits suicide;
something utterly tragic
erupts in his life.
And then the film continues,
and, all of a sudden,
there's a scent that shows
him frantically writing down.
And the narrator tells
us he felt guilty
over the creativity triggered
by his lover's death.
This notion that tragedy
can lead to breakthrough,
can lead to rebirth, that
the instances of suffering
in our lives can
actually inspire
us to make beautiful art is a
sort of paradoxical ecstasy,
that we can take our wounds, and
we can turn them into something
larger, that we need not
have suffered in vain game
is a wild idea, because
it doesn't mean that we
are happy for our suffering.
It doesn't mean that we
wished for these tragic things
to happen to us
as artists, but it
means that we're able
to take that pain,
take that aching rhapsody and
output something in the world
and make a contribution.
Because at least that
way, we validate the fact
that we exist.
We affirm ourselves.
We have no choice but to do so.
In the face of entropy,
in the face of death,
to not say that we exist
is to not live at all.